i just rang your door though because i
have a couple questions for you
are you sure are you positive
are you sure i just have a couple
questions for you
yeah can you hear me
uh what i'm looking for is for the girl
that's in the house to come out here
because i'm gonna rape her
that is a chilling encounter captured on
a ring doorbell camera
it happened last night near las vegas
boulevard in charleston
the man you see here was taken into
custody by district court marshals
after startling a valley woman and as
you heard they're threatening to rape
and kill her the woman says she posted
the video on social media hoping to warn
the neighborhood
and says she's happy he's off the
streets thanks to the power of social
media now
many of you watching are probably at
home right now and the situation really
reminds us how important it is to
lock the door check the deadpool just in
case a stranger knocks on your front
door
kate houston is live with some key ways
to stay safe and how that was important
for another woman in the same
neighborhood where this happened
kate
yes a few simple steps can ensure that
you and your family stay safe
inside of your home now erica washington
was forced to use some of these herself
when that same man approached her door
just a few months ago now washington
lives just down the street from the
woman who was threatened
near charleston and las vegas boulevard
washington monitored him through her
peephole and security camera
when he started knocking on her front
door when she repeatedly asked him to
leave
he started to scream and get aggressive
washington says
she immediately recognized him from the
video circulating
online for someone to just knock on your
door
and start screaming uh and and using a
lot of expletives and saying what they
might do to you
like it makes you scared it makes you
want to make sure you have alarm systems
that you have a ring other cameras
things like that and that you know your
neighbors
washington says this is not the first
time something like this has happened in
her neighborhood
she hopes that this will encourage the
community to address the ongoing issue
of homelessness
and mental health in our area so what do
you do if a stranger
knocks on your door the first thing
you're going to want to do is make sure
that deadbolt
is completely locked now after that you
could look through people if you have
one
you can check your security system to
really see who exactly
is out there now what you don't want to
do is open
that door you can yell out through the
door to ask who they are
and what do they want if the situation
escalates
you can call live kate 911 8 news now